thank you for joining us America Nick is
with us in Canton Ohio I'm Dave how are
you
I'm great Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up so I have a question
for you that I probably know what you're
going to say but I guess wanted it to
get your logic on it anyway so in short
I've got a car loan and I'm trying to
figure out if I should pay it off or not
my logic for not wanting to pay it off
mainly would just be for the sake of a
credit score and playing that game in
the relatively near future I'd be maybe
looking to rent potentially buy a house
I think I've heard you say before that
you might need a credit score to rent so
I just I guess that's my logic I wasn't
sure okay I don't know here we can we
can looking let's look at at two levels
one let's look at it at the overarching
idea and then let's look at the details
in your situation after that okay the
overarching idea of building a credit
score assumes that you're going to
borrow money are not paying off in the
case of your car why so that I have a
score that says that I pay money back
well which the credit score is 100%
determined by interaction with debt and
so so I'm borrowing money so that I have
a good credit score why so that I can
borrow money why so that I can have a
better credit score
why because borrowing money gets me my
dreams ultimately is what we're saying
and then when we drill down into that
the truth is is that the fastest path to
wealth which were from a money
perspective gives you your dreams the
fastest path to building wealth is to
use your most powerful wealth building
tool which is your income in other words
what you pay out in a car payment what
you pay out in a student loan payment
what you pay out in payments would make
you wealthy faster than buying crap that
you don't have the money to pay for and
so this whole idea of a dog chasing its
tail on the car
score you see what I'm saying is that
it's you know we're borrowing money why
so that we can borrow money why so that
we can borrow money why so that we can
borrow money that's the dog chasing its
tail yeah do you follow me and so you
can see a crazy dog run in circles and
we got half the culture as a crazy dog
running in circles and and yeah in
worship at the altar of the FICO score
as if the FICO score is your provider
when mathematically when we dig down
into it and we learn people that build
wealth what do they do
you know they just don't know other
people and that allows them to save
invest and give which is the shortest
path to wealth now that's the
overarching part now drill down into
your situation into the technicalities
you know if you're listening to Dave
Ramsey know you've never heard me say
that you have to have a credit score to
rent you have to have a credit score to
rent some places but you don't have to
have a credit score rent from me as an
example I'm a landlord I got a bunch of
rental property there's lots of people
like me out there that would look at a
sharp young guy who's you know got a
good job and doesn't have a credit score
which oh by the way you could remind
them means I don't have any payments
which what that means is I actually have
the money to pay your rent and so a
landlord would stop and go oh yeah now
there are corporate landlords who are
large property holders and they have
rules and they won't rent - if you don't
have credit score which means that I'm
worth tens of millions of dollars and
they wouldn't rent to me which kind of
has yet to but they are right I mean it
means I can go down here the corner
apartment complex and they might not
rent to me if their corporate owner
because I don't have a credit score I
can write a check and buy the complex
but I can't rent that that's how
ridiculous this is okay so yeah now so I
don't give people a pass on four credit
score purposes on borrowing money ever
for anything because you can work around
it and I have for 25 or 30 years now and
and so because I want to build wealth
and because I want to build wealth it
means I don't give money to these people
because an 800 credit score means you've
paid out at least $100,000 in interest
is the only way you got
it's impossible mathematically to get it
otherwise now so in your situation I
probably could pay the car off now the
one thing that does come up is okay how
do we buy a house I would buy a house
without a credit score you have to find
a mortgage lender and there's only about
one in 20 that know how to do it
about 19 out of 20 don't know how to do
it that can do manual underwriting which
is old-school underwriting for the loan
which is what we used to do back in the
day when I was in my 20s selling real
estate before there was a credit score
we actually would look and make we would
get verification that they had a job of
VO
a verification of employment a VOD
verification of deposit from the bank
that they had the money in the bank for
the down payment and we would go through
and confirm with the landlord in writing
that they currently were renting from
that they could that they were paying
the rent on time therefore we think they
might pay the mortgage on time and
that's called manual underwriting and
you can still get a mortgage with that
there it's not a higher interest rate
it's not a problem there's lots of
mortgage companies don't know how to do
that but there's you know there's one in
twenty or so that do and Churchill
mortgage that we endorse is one of them
and so what I would tell you based on
all of that jabbering is don't borrow
money but getting debts that you have
paid off because that's the shortest
path to wealth and if you're going to
borrow to buy a home do it with menu
underwriting and don't run around
worshipping at the altar of the FICO
score the more you do that the more
money you give to banks and you are you
become a dog chasing its tail I borrow
money why so that I have a good score
why so that I can borrow money why so
that I have a good score why so that I
can borrow more money and that's just
it's just a dog chasing its tail and
again the vast majority of culture is
that is that crazy but dog you know
chasing its tail and and they do you're
seeing going circles since they're nutty
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]